martin luther king ein eindrückliches filmdokument
über die hintergründe seiner ermordung und über
seinen einsatz für gewaltlosen widerstand gegen
rassentrennung und rassismus rassismus ist auch
in der schweiz verbreitet die formen sind
meist subtil nicht offensichtlich das besagen
verschiedene studien was ist rassismus und was
können wir gegen rassismus unternehmen darüber
diskutiere ich mit dennis f es ist soziologin und
forscht an der universität neuenburg sie hat vor
kurzem auch eine studie zum thema rassismus
in der schweiz veröffentlicht fatima moniz
ist sozial anthropologin und engagiert sich gegen
rassismus harmonie ist martin luther king für sie
ein vorbild wenn wir gerade diesen film gesehen
haben ja natürlich auf eine art vor allem auch
weil er ein sehr guter redner war ich glaube
dass wenn man über martin luther king spricht
oft einfach diese komponente der gewaltlosigkeit
und des noblen revolutionärs ein bisschen zu krass
betont weil es glaube ich wichtig ist zu sehen
dass die die die strategie die martin luther king
hatte war auf unrecht aufmerksam zu machen indem
man es demonstriert also man geht auf die straße
man wird angegriffen von der polizei und zeigt
somit dass das dass das böse gesicht der der der
rassistischen gewalt und die frage heute wäre für
mich ob das überhaupt noch funktioniert kann man
uns überhaupt noch schocken mit rassistischer
gewalt wie ist es denn in der schweiz heute ist
es gefährlich sich gegen rassismus einzusetzen
direkt gefährlich nicht also tätigkeiten gibt es
in der schweiz zum glück selten aber es ist ein
schwieriges thema es ist ein gesamtes thema wie
ich auch gemerkt habe als ich diese studie zum
rassismus gegen schwarze personen insbesondere
gemacht habe war ich recht erstaunt dass das thema
durch noch so umtreibt und relativ unglaublich amt
ist weil das jahre her ist mit martin luther
king in amerika eine andere situation aber was
haben sie denn da herausgefunden oder was hat sie
so erstaunt das ist schwierig ist über rassismus
zu sprechen weil die betroffenen selbst die
schwarzen frauen und männer vermeiden dass
weil sie auch oft merken dass es unbequem ist
weil viele weiße eigentlich sich mit rassismus
gar nicht unbedingt konfrontieren möchten
und auch nicht müssen wenn sie denn nicht
konkret bezüge haben zb in der familie oder
an der arbeit ich möchte mal bei ihnen noch
anknüpfen sie haben ja gesagt auch die rhetorik
von martin luther king hat sie beeindruckt sie
sind ja auch spoken word poetry sie haben vor
wenigen tagen bei den schweizer meisterschaften
im poetry slam in winterthur gemeinsam mit laurin
buser den zweiten platz gewonnen rassismus ist
auch manchmal bei ihren auftritten ein thema
wie im folgenden filmausschnitt am rassismus
kritischen festival in der roten fabrik in zürich
im jahr 2015 wir sehen hier wie sie auch mit witz
und humor gegen rassismus ankämpfen rassismus
ich muss er immer über rassismus reden also die
beste geschichte war eigentlich dieser typ der
so hinter die bühne kommt zu mir und und wissen
will wo ich herkomme und ich will gerade ausholen
thomas beyer noch so aus münchen ja weil freilich
und so da da da unterbricht er mich und erzählt
mir er sei auch schon auf dem kilimandscharo
gewesen ich frage mich wo kommt das jetzt her
aber dann fällt mir eins vielleicht so afrika
und dann fragt er mich aber im nächsten schritt
also wie ich denn afrika so und ich sage ja sie
sind doch schon auf dem kilimandscharo gewesen
sagt ja ich bin ja nur wanderer xiii ich bin
nur wandert mit afrikanern schwarz habe ich gesagt
aber die frau die frau ist ein wunderschönes share
incentive sie ja manchmal bleibt einem das lachen
im hals stecken ist dann aber jetzt diese frage
woher sie kommen die frage nach der herkunft
ist die schon rassistisch latent rassistisch
ich glaube es ist einfach die frage zu stellen
ob sie angebracht ist das ding mit der frage
ist natürlich dass ich die frage andauernd
gestellt bekomme überall und einfach mega oft
also egal wo ich bin und wenn man über die frage
nachdenken ist das eine relativ intime frage auch
also wenn sie sich überlegen wann erzählen
sie von ihren eltern in einem gespräch wenn
sie jemanden kennenlernen der straße schon oder
genau und ist es passiert wirklich manchmal dass
leute an der tramhaltestelle auf mich zukommen
und sagen wo kommen sie denn eigentlich her und
das suggeriert natürlich auch dass ich nicht von
hier bin also dass das zeigt mir ganz klar du bist
anders und gleichzeitig bin ich in deutschland
aufgewachsen geboren ich spreche deutsch das ist
meine hauptsprache ich gehöre zu deutschland und
inzwischen auch zur schweiz ich spreche inzwischen
schweizer deutlich gegen die uni und so weiter
dieses dieses ständige suggerieren dass das man
nicht daher kommt das ist glaube ich dass das
das problem die frage ob das rassistisch ist
ist natürlich heikel war leute rassistisch sein
wollen ich glaube aber dass wir alle in einem
rassistischen system aufgewachsen sind und daher
gar nicht anders können als rassistisch zu sein
das heißt dass wir dass es vollkommen normal ist
beispielsweise mit ok man kann da in gefahr ich
glaube die definition von rassismus ist erstmal
wichtig dass man dass man sich überlegt okay was
bedeutet rassismus für mich bedeutet das
und was mir ganz besonders wichtig sind
sind zwei komponenten einerseits historizität
also dass irgendwas mit einer geschichte zu
tun hat für mich ganz klar die geschichte in der
festgelegt worden ist was rassen sind weil es ja
eigentlich gar keine rassen gibt und die andere
komponente ist ist macht also dass es wirklich
auch auswirkungen hat das jemand rassistisch
über dich denkstrukturen die tief gehen ist war
das ein thema bei ihnen das ist schon da anfängt
in dieser studie mit der frage woher kommen sie
das wurde oft gesagt und dieser alltagsrassismus
der sich eben mehr die das von ihnen gesagt wurde
mehr durch die repetition eigentlich mühsam
wird der erde ist schwierig insbesondere auch
für jugendliche und junge menschen die hier
aufgewachsen sind sich genau bewegen wie alle
anderen schweizer genauso angezogen von den
gleichen dialekt sprechen und dass ihnen dann
trotzdem immer diese frage gestellt wird und das
heißt wenn jemand als touristen oder tourist da
ist ist die frage woher kommen sie eine andere
und liegt anders also eben für mich ist deutlich
wo ist die grenze zwischen interesse und wo sie
vielleicht sagen ich würde sie sagen subtilen
rassismus ja ich denke schon dass das das subtile
rassismus zum ausdruck kommt letzten endes macht
ja auch der ton ein bisschen die musik also es
kann dann sein dass sich dahin treten auch diese
frage liegt sicher würden vielleicht gar nicht
hierher das muss nicht sein es kann natürlich
auch ein interesse seien aber letzten endes muss
man ja sehen wie die die betroffenen darf erleben
und ich finde da ist ganz wichtig dass man eben
mal fragt nach fragt wie geht es ihnen wenn sie
immer wieder gefragt werden eine frau die wir
in der studie befragt hatten arbeitet in einem
spital und sich aktiv sie werde jetzt demnächst
ein t shirt tragen wo darauf steht ich komme aus
dem kongo und lebe seit 30 jahren den in der
schweiz weil sie einfach taktisch gefragt wird
und ich glaube nicht immer mit den intentionen
aber ab und zu ich glaube so der punkte von der
intention ist auch noch wichtig wenn man über
rassismus redet weil ich glaube dass intention
nichts mit rassismus zu tun hat natürlich wenn wir
über rassismus reden wollen wir immer über die svp
reden oder aber ich hab schon heraus gehört bei
ihnen wir können gar nicht anders habe ich vorhin
raus gehört in ihrer studie steht wir haben da ein
zitat vorbereitet alle befragten personen erwähnen
erfahrungen oder beobachtungen rassistischen
verhaltens situationen oder einstellungen in
unterschiedlichen lebensbereichen ich finde das
ist schon schwer wiegen diese feststellung also
das hat mich persönlich auch erstaunt also wir
haben ja nur schwarze personen befragt und alle
haben irgendwann selbst oder in ihrem umfeld
rassismus getroffen oder diskriminierung erlebt
und die frage ist dann natürlich wie schwerwiegend
war das wie häufig ist das passiert da kann man
sich darüber unterhalten aber ich glaube das
kontrastiert ein bisschen mit dem bild das
man sich eben von der schweiz ab und zu macht wir
sind doch ein weltoffenes land und da gibt es doch
rassismus nicht also was wirklich präzisieren
die studie heißt amtlich schwarzen rassismus
also explizites nicht allgemein rassistische
diskriminierungen sondern an die schwarzen
rassismus in der schweiz eine bestandesaufnahme
oktober 2017 können sie uns zwei drei beispiele
geben wie das im alltag vorkommt ja zum beispiel
eine frau die einkaufen will in einem laden und
dann werden plötzlich neben ihr unten bedient
die nach ihr gekommen sind und sie wird gar nicht
gefragt was sie denn eigentlich kaufen möchte
also dann solche dinge existieren eben nach wie
vor das ist jetzt schon ein relativ stark dass es
muss wirklich mal fragen also habe gelesen dass
beispiele gibt menschen die dann aufstehen im bus
oder tram wenn sich eine schwarze person hin setzt
das haben wir öfters oder sogar schwarze menschen
anschauen und ihnen zu verstehen geben sie müssten
aufstehen wenn andere leute in den bus einsteigen
weil die wie eine art priorität hätten dass das
sind alles ebenso manifestationen die es gibt ich
glaube nicht dass das die mehrheit wie erleben
sie das ja also ich habe auch noch nie irgendwie
gewalttätigen rassismus an mir selbst erlebt ich
glaube so diesen alltagsrassismus das ist das
ist normal und das aber eben genau weil es eben
weil wir damit aufwachsen dass es normal ist dass
man zum beispiel gerade nach dem abitur oder nach
der matur nach afrika reist und die welt rettet es
ist normal dass wir indianer figuren spielen und
überhaupt nicht im kopf haben was das eigentlich
für eine geschichte hat es ist normal dass david
signer zum beispiel der afrika korrespondent von
der sz jedes mal aufs neue irgendwie exotische
geschichten über afrika erzählt und haben daher
hexerei und unten dass das prägt uns natürlich
alles entsteht ein bild genau sich und und
dass das muss ich gar nicht erst in gewalt
ausüben also dass das viel viel von rassismus
entsteht ja dann auch irgendwie in unterbewusst
also sachen dass ich mich nicht neben jemandem
setzte der schwarzes oder ein kopftuch hat oder
irgendwie gefährlich aussieht dass das kann
auch was unterbewusstsein und er wird ja dann
auch immer wieder re aktualisiert also es ging für
diese idee der wird dann mit der zeit aussterben
und ältere menschen sind ein bisschen raffinierter
als jüngere aber das stimmt eben nicht weil gerade
wie sie jetzt gesagt haben in den medien wird und
nicht nur da die medien sind natürlich ein abbild
der bevölkerung aber werden solche bilder auch re
aktualisiert auch durch die politik da werden sie
zum teil sehr gezielt auch instrumentalisiert
racial profiling also polizeikontrollen mit
klarem raster schwarze meist junge männer ist ein
großes thema in der studie also bei den schwarzen
ich habe gesehen bei den muslimen kommt dass auch
vor natürlich aber etwas wie weniger aber bei den
schwarzen ist das ganz klar das thema nummer eins
natürlich er bei den männern aus bei den frauen
obwohl es geht sind beide geschlechter betroffen
und da für mich ja interessant wie viele leute
in der breiten bevölkerung also nicht nur svp
wähler das tatsächlich unterstützten wie viele
leute sagen ja also was soll man denn machen es
gibt eben mehr schwarze drogendealer also dass
das da diese logik von die auch durchsetztes mit
rassistischen gedanken dass die vollkommen normal
normal ist also und das spielt wahrscheinlich
zum beispiel das ist aus den gesprächen hält
vorgekommen dass zum beispiel die asylpolitik da
auch eine rolle spielen kann dass es nicht bewusst
aber das ist eben diese strukturellen rassismus
wo einerseits eben unerwünschte asylsuchende im
zusammenhang mit drogenhandel und dann eben mit
kriminalität gesetzt werden und das wieder ja
dass das überträgt sich dann auch auf die anderen
personen überhaupt nichts mit asyl und schon gar
nichts mit drogen zu tun haben das heißt das sind
wir bei einem thema was rassismus anbelangt es
wird ein bild dann für alle übergestülpt und
wenn es negativ ist ja wie ist es bei ihrem
namen regional werden sie auch gefragt woher sie
kommen ja das werde ich relativ regelmäßig oder es
gibt auch leute die gar nicht versuchen meinen
namen auszusprechen das finde ich ist ja nicht
so kompliziert es gibt so ellenlange ruandische
nahmen die wirklich schwierig auszusprechen sind
aber regional wie finde ich jetzt nicht sehr
kompliziert aber effektiv gibt es leute die
fragen da habe ich kein problem ableben die sich
zum beispiel gar nicht bemühen und mich dann mit
meinem mädchennamen ansprechen und wie antworten
sie auf die frage wenn sie so oft kommt wie gehen
sie damit um ich habe so verschiedene strategien
je nachdem wie viel kapazitäten und lustig habe
also manchmal spiele ich tatsächlich das spiel
durchaus möglichen 1 aus wirklich und irgendwann
sage ich aus der meiner mama dann ist meist nicht
still inzwischen manchmal finde ich auch irgendwas
je nach dem manchmal dass burkina faso sierra
leone irgendwas exotisches weil ich das gefühl
habe dass leute das ja auch gar nicht wirklich
wissen wollen die fragen die hinterher kommen sind
immer die gleichen es ist immer so okay da hab
ich dann habe anfassen oder muss man der kopftuch
tragen also ich hab das gefühl meistens ist die
frage dann auch irgendwie ein komischer einstieg
für ein gespräch das einem aufgedrückt wird also
ich muss dann mit jemandem über sein wolle und
ihr aufenthalt in kenia leben also das heißt das
heißt ich inzwischen beantwortet die frage auch
gar nicht mehr ernsthaft außer es kommt wirklich
in einem gespräch das ist ja auch wirklich was
anderes wenn wenn man in einer situation ist in
dem die frage tatsächlich natürlich gewachsen
kommt das was ich vorhin gefragt hat wo die
grenze ist und menschen interesse und eben
vorgefertigten sozusagen hut der übergestülpt wird
ich möchte auch ein anderes thema ansprechen und
zwar muslimfeindlichkeit bundesrat alle besser
schreibt im vorwort zum rassismus bericht des
bundes aus dem jahr 2016 rassismus ist vielfältig
muslimfeindlichkeit rassismus gegenüber schwarzen
gegenüber menschen mitfahrender lebensweise
antisemitismus und weitere formen haben ihre
je eigene geschichte und mechanismen wir
haben jetzt auch schon differenziert aber
hier in diesem bericht geht es jetzt wirklich um
rassistische diskriminierung und rassismus wird
als oberbegriff gebracht was ist jetzt rassismus
wie definieren sie das also es gibt keine
allgemein akzeptierte definition des rassismus
dass das ist wahrscheinlich auch so weil er eben
im verlauf der zeit auch hier sehr kontroversen
oberbegriff wie es hier gebraucht wird genauso
häufig unterscheidet man zwischen rassistischer
diskriminierung und dem rassismus als ideologie
aber wir haben vorhin gesehen man muss nicht
unbedingt eine ideologie einer rassistischen
die haben um dann auch rassistisch zu handeln
also das thema was sie ansprechen möchte ist
muslimfeindlichkeit wird hier auch geht das auch
unter wasser es muss also ich würde es sagen schon
obwohl die frage ob muslimfeindlichkeit jetzt
insgesamt rassistisch ist oder ob es auch einen
teil gibt die zum beispiel eine gewisse angst vor
den muslimen bezeichnet die noch nicht direkt mit
rassistisch rassistisch bezeichnet werden konnte
das ist auch umstritten und ich glaube da kann
man die grenzen auch nicht so genau 4 das heißt
aber sie sind muslimin wenn sie als schwarze und
muslimen sind sie mehrfach von diskriminierung
betroffen ich glaube was man natürlich da noch
dazu sagen muss dass ich kein kopftuch trage ich
bin nicht offensichtlich muslime ich glaube dass
das leute die die wirklich offensichtlich
muslimisch sind oder sichtbar ganz andere
reaktionen bekommen und ich weiß von von von
freundinnen dass das die wirklich tagtäglich
auch gewaltvolle übergriffe haben in form von
angespuckt werden angerempelt werden und bei mir
äußert sich dass er so ab dem moment in dem das
gegenüber erfährt dass ich muslim ich bin merke
ich okay jetzt wird plötzlich abgecheckt
ob ich auch ausrechnen feministisch sein
kann ob ich menschenrechte unterschreiben
würde und so wird dann geprüft welche art
von islam oder genau aber ich wollte da noch
was dazu sagen ich glaube was was was bei der
frage ob islamfeindlichkeit oder islamophobie
jetzt rassismus ist was bei der frage wichtig
ist ist dass man klar stellt dass rassismus
auch schon immer was mit mit mit religion zu
tun hat rassismus wurde durch religion ja auch
die wege geleitet und legitimiert und deswegen
kommt ja oft so das argument islamophobie
ist kein rassismus weil religion ist keine
rasse so ein bisschen komisch einfach weil es
rasten ja sowieso nicht die verbindung führen
sie auf die geschichte zurück und es muss genau
in dem sohne minderwertigkeit durch einen nicht
glauben an die gleichen werte oder gleichen
götter gottheiten zurückgeführt wird auf eine
allgemeine menschliche minderheit oder dass du
das dass man wirklich gesagt hat okay dass das
es biblisch belegt dass das keine menschen sind
und deswegen dürfen wir sie auch abschlachten zu
muslimfeindlichkeit weil ich gerne über die
situation in der schweiz sprechen möchte aktuell
gibt es eine pilotstudie vom gfs bern pilotstudie
diskriminierungserfahrungen von muslimen in der
schweiz da steht verbreitet sind insbesondere
die ist aktuell januar 2018 verbreitet sind
insbesondere direkte und indirekte erfahrungen
von hasskriminalität und diskriminierungen und
zwar in den allermeisten fällen eindeutig auf
grund der erkennbarkeit der zugehörigkeit zur
muslimischen gemeinde beispielsweise wegen
eines kopftuchs oder wegen des namens also
die sichtbarkeit ist eben auch ganz wichtig
und kürzlich wurde in deutschland auch eine
studie veröffentlicht wo sie verglichen haben
verschiedene herkunftsgruppen die sichtbar
waren oder eben nicht also bei ihnen kann man
ja nicht sehen ob sie muslime sind zb aber je
nach dem eben wenn sie ein kopftuch tragen würden
würde man das sehen und sobald die leute sichtbar
sind werden sie wesentlich mehr diskriminiert als
wenn das eben nicht sichtbar ist wenn gestern erst
in einem gespräch zum ausdruck kommt und in dem
sinn ist also ich glaube heute ist wahrscheinlich
die muslimfeindlichkeit obwohl es macht keinen
sinn die verschiedenen rassismen gegeneinander
auszuspielen aber die muslimfeindlichkeit ist
relativ aktuell und öffnet wird fasst vielleicht
noch noch direkter angesprochen als zum beispiel
der rassismus gegen schwarze da gibt es eine
größere zurückhaltung weil man wahrscheinlich
die geschichte kennt und weiß ich verdient das
ist und die die muslimfeindlichkeit das finde
ich auch erstaunen und das belegen inzwischen
in der schweiz gibt es nicht sehr viele studien
aber es gibt inzwischen einige und sie belegen
alle dass man sich da ein bisschen gehen lässt
und ich hier gibt es den erkenntnisse wo die
ursachen dafür liegen also die medien die
die betroffenen muslime in der studie sagen
ja auch und dass sie das gefühl haben dass
das in den medien auch verstärkt wird und es
hat sich etwas damit zu tun mit dem weltweiten
terrorismus und mit der art wie das eben hier
auch präsentiert und dann rezitiert wie oder
muslimen muslime unter generalverdacht geraten
also ich glaube dass es da auch interessantes wenn
man also dass die debatte dann interessantes als
paradebeispiel dafür wie rassismus eigentlich
alle bevölkerungsschichten auch wirklich durch
durchtränkt wenn man zum beispiel daran denkt
wie wii vollkommen natürliches ist wie über
das kopftuch gesprochen wird das ist vollkommen
akzeptiert es in unserer gesellschaft dass wir
ohne muslimas zu fragen darüber sprechen ob es
jetzt okay ist oder nicht dass sie ein kopftuch
tragen wenn wir plötzlich anfangen über werte zu
diskutieren und uns darauf einlassen und darauf
einzuschränken dass die schweiz bestimmte werte
hat und die europäisch und christlich sind und
europa bestimmte wert hat die dir klar europäische
und christlich sind und dabei die ganze geschichte
in der ja auch zusammentreffen mit mit dem
islam und so weiter stattgefunden haben
einfach beiseite schiebt und so ein bisschen unter
den teppich schiebt um so eine so eine lineare
geschichtsschreibung von wir gegen die zu zu
machen was dieses bild nochmals verstärkt es gibt
ja rassistische diskriminierung auch gegenüber
juden juden von einem vorfall letzten tagen
gelesen eine holocaust-überlebende die umgebracht
wurde ja auch das ist noch aktuell und ich glaube
das unterstreicht auch einmal mehr dass eben
der rassismus sehr verschiedene gesichter haben
kann und es stimmt dass bei gewissen ausschließen
beispiel ist wirklich diese idee dass zb schwarze
etwas dünner sind als weiße dass es so etwas was
manchmal welt kreiert wird bei den juden kommen
eben immer noch so vorurteile wie dass sie geld
süchtig sind dass er seine weltweite verschwörung
gibt und all diese die diese anachronistische
vorurteile die eigentlich alle widerlegt sind
werten hat einfach immer bietet trotzdem
besprochen und lief sitzen so gegen ende
unseres gesprächs wo setzen sie an sie geben
auch workshops gegen rassismus was machen sie
da konkret hauptsächlich versuchen wir ich mache
das mit einem kollegen die hauptsächlich versuchen
wir einen raum zu schaffen in dem offen darüber
geredet werden kann weil man das auch schon in
schulklassen sieht man redet nicht mehr darüber
man hat irgendwie von zu hause von den medien von
überall her irgendwelche annahmen und und und
die sind dann einfach fest und da sitzen dann
vielleicht zwei kinder in einer klasse dass wir
bei unserem ersten workshops so der der eine war
schwarz und bei der frage wie oft er kontrolliert
wird von der polizei sagte er sehr oft den
wöchentlich ein 16 jähriger junge und ob er angst
habe vor der polizei ja und gegenübersitzt von ihm
ein weißer schüler der sagt wenn er kontrolliert
wird was jetzt zwei mal vorgekommen ist dann fragt
er ich will erst mal ihren ausweis sehen und
so diese diese unterschiede also ja fragt ein
polizist genau da hakt es im osten nach nachdem
was empfehlen sie aber stoppt moment ihre das
will ich noch fertig sagen dass diese unterschiede
das zusehen mega wichtig sind um erkennen welche
privilegien man hat oder eine wunsch sei es
bildung diese also ich denke das ist etwas
ganz wichtiges dass wir darüber sprechen und dass
insbesondere die betroffenen darüber sprechen und
eben dass man diese hemmungen abbaut und eben
auch zuhört weil häufig gibt es so ein bisschen
die reaktion das dann herunterspielen zu wollen
das ist ja nicht so schlimm und überhaupt und
ich habe gemerkt dass eben auf also das ist uns
natürlich bei der studie von den schwarzen ist
das gespiegelt wurden von der mehrheitsbevölkerung
dass die einfach zum teil wirklich ein wenig weiß
und sich gar nicht vorstellen kann was das eben
heißt wenn man auf dem schulweg kontrolliert wird
von der polizei aber ich glaube da ist es ist
nicht die sache von von den betroffenen darüber
mehr zu reden oder sich da mehr politik zu machen
ich glaube das ist genau der punkt dass das leute
die nicht von rassismus betroffen sind erkennen
müssen und lernen müssen bevor sie sich an den
tisch setzen und über rassismus also dass man
dass man sich weiter schult darüber welche
privilegien man hat dass man dass man sein
auge schult dafür was wie ich jetzt anders
behandelt werden als die person die da gerade am
putzen es wäre es eigentlich am putzen wer ist in
welcher gesellschaftlichen rolle was passiert
wenn ich mit vollmond esse wird das auf meinem
eine rasse zurückgeführt so sachen dass ich dass
ich wirklich ein gespür dafür entwickeln welche
stellung in der gesellschaft haben und nicht
wieder abwälze auf auf die die sich mal wieder
integrieren sollen oder die die einfach den mund
aufmachen müssen noch ganz gut keinesfalls aber
ich finde es ganz wichtig dass man eben zu hören
und vielleicht auch mal wirklich still ist und mal
zuhört wie geht zb rassismus erlebt und ich denke
die mehrheitsgesellschaft weist das einfach nicht
hier ganz herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
ihnen beiden danke danke auch hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit dem philosophischen stammtisch und
einer debatte über macht und wirkung der medien
hallo